all right welcome back to another
episode of chappelle's world and my
guest today
mr
white mike
i'll give him his real name it's michael
turner come on now at turner comedy yeah
uh i'm excited to have not only my
roommate
best friend
on my podcast the only reason why i had
him on is because
you know he was on cats after dark and
he was like man chappelle got a whole
ass podcast as a
you know what's funny is yeah
was like man i should listen to all
these podcasts before i jump on i heard
toby's he's been on three times
i've known you three times longer than
toby
that's fair that's all fair hey i live
in chapel's world it's just an apartment
yep he was right by the world no it's
actually kind of cool to have you on
uh one because you were you you were
well received on cats after dark uh and
also because uh
i don't know if you guys know this about
white mike you've probably seen his
clips you probably seen his stand-up
stuff on instagram but his uh music
knowledge
runs deep oh yeah
i mean
i i don't know what genre to start at
with him but there's so many there's so
many because
in um
and i feel like it's like developed your
style as a person
is that fair dude i think i think about
that a lot i actually think it
correlates to my
stand up a lot too the fact that like
and i think you probably don't i don't
know if you ever think about this
um with your stand up but i was talking
to somebody recently about how
i think my pacing and stuff like that is
all really influenced by my level of
just being obsessed with music at an
early age and like listening to music
yeah because pacing on stage what we're
doing in stand-up is sometimes very
musical the timing yeah it can be very
musical because sometimes you say a
sentence but if i t if i say that
sentence monotone or something like that
it's not funny but if you bring it up or
bring it down it's almost yeah like uh
with notes yeah yeah yeah so it's a flat
line
it's not stagnant right if it is
stagnant it's probably bad unless you're
like uh you know what's his name uh
stephen wright exactly
and that [ __ ] is actually its own
uh genius and in the monotonous but like
if you really think the monotone the
monotone still has a
level of like
rhythm to it
yeah if you go well then they would be
like the counterbalance because
sometimes if you're high pitched
whatever then you bring it back to the
monotone then that's the art right it's
like the break beat that's like like we
both love yeah i've been obsessed
recently again if you're talking about
like where to start with things um i
think my biggest level of like knowledge
and love is hip hop for sure oh yeah 100
um and i was listening i've been bumping
uh fantastic volume two a lot lately
with j dilla dude who is you you
introduced me to that album so the
fantastic volume two album is slum
village slum villain those that don't
know yep
get into that album it's from top to
bottom yeah that album i remember we
just took we took a drive to uh we it
was during the pandemic it's probably in
arizona yeah we took a drive to arizona
yeah right and that was the album
when we went there and also when we went
back because i i like when you played it
i became obsessed because all i knew of
slum village was the uh oh selfish the
big hit yeah selfish yeah which is which
was
because a lot of people when when dilla
passed or that back end of when dilla
wasn't with slum as much
all the producers wanted to help them as
much as i could because they loved what
that album yeah if you don't if you have
no no knowledge of it or anything a lot
of people probably do know that selfish
song like yeah everyone it's a big song
everyone everyone knows selfish and uh
big songs and if you if you don't you do
right it's like one of those like play
right now you'd be like oh [ __ ] i
remember this um as long as you were
cool in 2006. yeah was that 2002
2004 probably 2004. yeah and um and that
was my introduction to slum village too
i was like oh i love this song i love
you guys
i actually
so here's my favorite thing is the
perspective on dilla in general to me
was nuts so i was just a dude that loved
hip-hop in this episode might get dilla
heavy come on
have you ever talked about dylan here no
i don't really want to do it because
because i don't know too many people
that know him on the level that you do
because that's what makes it tough
sometimes you know like
i i mean i can sit here and talk about
it but it it just be boring but to have
another person
and i'd rather have the person that
introduced me to dylan
yeah there you go well he's it's it's
like one of the
coolest dives in music you can take
because it's not like it's not just
hip-hop it is a lot of really amazing r
b some of the best r b of the early
2000's rocking with d'angelo d'angelo
erica badou yeah y'all know deangelo
y'all seen that video if you don't
you're probably a virgin yeah you
understand
imagine not knowing deanzo it's like oh
damn yeah you ain't never had sex yeah
what happens after third base yeah um
but
my my favorite thing about my
introduction at dilla was the fact that
like i was just a big hip-hop head
growing up
and um i loved that slump village song
and then they then you buy then you go
to best buy when the release comes out
you buy it on tuesday for 9.99 yeah
cause then they're going to increase the
15.99 and i'm in between checks in
between 16 year olds yeah so i got
montgomery uh i was at montgomery inn
montgomery and our dealership that's
tony
if you cincy you know montgomery oh yeah
it's first job ever
the real one the real all montgomery
road what are we talking about shout out
to tommy gregory yeah
so i was getting cds like that and so i
really enjoyed that album
and then i you know within that album
they talk about this dude dylan but by
then dylan them had split up
and then
i also loved one of my favorite albums
ever i stole it from my brother john who
you know yeah shout out to jt and a lot
of my influence comes from my older
brother right because i was a younger
brother just stealing cds
and um and so i got he had an album
called uh like waterford chocolate by
common
which is one of the greatest
hi
this needs to be like james uh lipton
inside the active studio yeah right when
he mentions something yeah and they just
go yeah
yeah yeah
casey where are you at doug yeah that's
what's good
this needs to be that's exactly what it
needs to be
like water for chocolate
and then yeah and then he came out with
like water yeah
and like water for chocolate was
a common album i was obsessed with this
album i actually thought it was like it
was it was it's such a good album also
it's a timeless album it has the song
the light on it which ended up being one
of common's biggest song yeah
the dude is white the dude is white the
guys what's that guy's name um i gotta
look at it
i know it's like what is his name
because dre's used them used this stuff
before too um look up the light sample
yeah the light sample
what's that dude's name common yeah
common
um bobby caldwell bobby caldwell yeah
now let's do google images of bobby
caldwell
all right yeah because this is we can't
we can't play well the best thing is
but common
didn't even know
common common made this whole song go to
the one word
not that one go to go to
go to the picture with the
the uh second picture at the top oh yeah
my man that's my man right now that's
how everybody knows them roberto roberto
that's the dude dude so kyle there's
there's an interview on the internet
somewhere where commons like he's like
finds out he was white he's like oh god
i didn't know either like until he had
already made the song
so i loved like albums like that and i
grew up loving like um
you know there was a de la soul album
that i really was obsessed with and [ __ ]
like that so all that toby you get down
on that one all that yeah and it was
late daylight i got into like the time
date oh the grind date oh okay okay the
grinder yeah
yeah it was come on man
that [ __ ] was all very influential to me
and like huge albums so i say all that
because it was cool because i didn't
really get into
i didn't discover who j dillard was
until 0.506
and
and unfortunately by that time he had
passed he's he was like i think i
discovered him right before he was like
he was about to die or he died because
yeah i hate this thing that people say
whenever you discover someone
after they pass and they're like oh you
didn't even and but it's like let people
have let people have that like let the
legacy of that person
like
if people don't like it's like with
nipsey yeah like oh you didn't really
know who he was until he passed and it's
like okay so if people did so also my
favorite thing that i've i used to have
that too like i wasn't like i used to be
like that i used to be like dad a little
bit taller because i'd be like oh you
didn't know about it
yeah
i
i my my perspective and obviously we're
older now right because the right
perspective to have on that is not to be
like oh you didn't know about it then i
actually now i flipping i'm like i'm
jealous of you because you get to
discover this whole thing yeah with
these more grown eyes
but as a person that discovered it after
it keeps it growing yes right you know
what i'm saying yes it keeps you
refreshed tell somebody else about this
when you exactly and then all of a
sudden it just keeps it it just keeps
going you find out more and more and
more i love the the slum village album
is one of my favorite ones to to hit
people with because
it's timeless okay so hold on
so okay at what age or do you do you
have any recollection of when you said
yes to music
um
i was i don't think i even had a choice
it was my house it was just your house
it was like it wasn't even in my house
it was long road trips with my mom
and yeah shout out to mimi turner and
she
had a tape you guys you got to shout out
me me the tape was the tape was uh
les mis
uh oh y'all was getting down with me we
were doing show time
oh yeah you told me y'all went and saw
cats oh yeah i walked out of that [ __ ]
i was like they got cats running around
in full adult cats like well y'all hit
different in cincinnati well my mom so
my mom's from new york
so she like loved all that [ __ ] oh yeah
she grew up makes sense yeah so we like
knew all the [ __ ] i never even seen a
west side story but i know all the songs
i feel like you and i are the same way
in the this you we have this unique
thing about it it's similar to what you
said earlier pretty much about
we just have this wide fascination from
music yeah and it uh
kind of helps it kind of help develop
our personalities in a sense and help us
deliver
what we want to deliver to the world
whether it be stand-up or just existing
in general
yeah yeah i mean i think i've learned
more
about myself and
kind of how to communicate through boys
come on come on hey what what it was
juan yeah hey
on what's the video
dog the bridge of boys
name a more impactful moment in music
than when
the bridge would hit in a boys and men's
song any boys i don't even know
my problem
say i'm sorry stop on anything
dude when they were i love that the boy
cement is my favorite thing because it
would just be like
all right we'll write two verses and
then what we're going to do and then
juania would walk in and be like i'ma
[ __ ] this bridge up that's what i'm
gonna do
i'm gonna treat this one
yeah let me let me take it right i'm
gonna treat this bridge like a real good
combat strategy in world war ii yeah and
we're gonna break this [ __ ] down
um
but yeah so that it was it was
definitely forced upon me with my
my mom with show tunes and then like we
were always really musically
um you know just surrounded by music so
long road trips weren't
um you know just radio or something it
was like that we're putting in this tape
you know whitney houston was a tape we
would we would listen to oh no stop
playing um and then my dad loved music
too but he was different he loved
different music um you know not to say
my mom didn't like the eagles and steely
dan but that was more like
his [ __ ]
he put me on to that type of [ __ ]
also the crazy the crazy perspective i
love about
how i was raised was
my mom was born in 1947 my dad was born
in 1943. so i have older parents yeah so
i they were almost 40 my mom was almost
40 when i was born my dad was already
43.
oh wow so i was actually raised
a lot of people that around our age yeah
especially like i was raised around a
bunch of
i we had a good amount of diversity
growing up but at the end of the day i
was still in the suburbs of cincinnati
like a lot of white kids still and a lot
of my friends were
parents were raised on john cougar
mellon camp and like
maybe more billy joel like late billy
joel and [ __ ] yeah but my dad was like
joel by my dad was like
i was listening to like
definitely the beatles uh definitely the
beach boys the beach boys was huge but
then like really that old [ __ ] like uh
you know like [ __ ] bobby darren and
like mack the knife and [ __ ] like that i
knew growing up so like yeah
yeah that's crazy so like you know what
i'm saying like you know the whole beach
boy's charles manson here i know well i
didn't know all that [ __ ] the the later
stories
the real stories i didn't know until now
i just gave him a deal now i'm very yes
not very well versed on chucky manson
cincinnati boy he's cincinnati remember
we looked it up oh yeah we did we didn't
know born in cincinnati
yeah but i don't think cincinnati claims
him
you know what i'll claim him i mean
there's a dude that put it down dude
talk about mind control dude yeah
michael i got mine control of d-box yeah
yeah
yeah
that's just wow but like so
there was different [ __ ] like that and
my dad was
he was into he wasn't into it but we
would just listen to the old school [ __ ]
like sam cook and
i remember being like dude i remember
being like 14 well in it i mean he just
liked
he loved music too and he also liked
talk radio too so that was weird but
like um npr [ __ ] no like like mike
savage like the exact opposite of npr oh
yeah yeah
the polar hops oh really okay shout out
to rush limbo
you mean the band rush no i'm talking
about mr lim
tom sawyer no no no different different
rush uh but uh
yeah so it's
i was definitely raised by that type of
[ __ ]
and then
then the 90s hit and i think the 90s
were very musical anyway that was the
other thing because you were 86 or 87 87
like a couple months ago we're only a
couple months apart because i'm like
late 86 so like we're we were think
about it we were
eight nine ten years old
when like [ __ ] the cranberries were
just ripping through man like there's an
era like there's something about the the
90s era that i don't know
i'm not
i don't know what to say but there was
something so dominant about like okay
put it this way look at that flyer
behind you yeah reading 1992. like all
those bands on there i mean that's more
i don't know a lot of them but i know
some but yeah yeah but like that era
you know was a very popping era public
enemy and nirvana on the same [ __ ]
exactly and the rollins brand in little
font yeah i mean
he was just trying to figure it out
again yeah
but honey
come on yeah
all of it
i'm trying to see what else you would
know on that's wild why do i know l7 i
feel like i know that's a
female band
uh you know smashing pumpkins obviously
on there is smashing come on yeah yeah
they're they're on the same uh night as
public oh frankie side bottom come on
now
the comedy tent gee golly
but yeah i i i think about that too a
lot i think that
i've been actually trying to take this
on stage in the comedy senses like how
we've i think we we have
in the world right now i think we've got
our generation or our middle 30s
um have a very unique perspective on the
current world right now because
we do remember this time before i always
before before those buildings fell
before those buildings before those
buildings fell
we
i do honestly
i always say it not you know where you
make jess of it but it's like when you
know where you're when 2001 happened
like the whole world changed you can't
deny that
everything's shifted
yeah because it took a little bit but it
didn't change like right overnight but
like everything changed and i say that
because the 90s were the last era where
we had like
i don't know i just felt little space
personal space personal privacy a little
bit more even though we didn't but we
had the perception of it we had
everything was really happy it was
jubilant that we had a surplus in the
budget like oh yeah clinton was out here
getting money baby money come on now
y'all remember that whose remember is
that you really who does yeah yeah i
forget casey 37 yeah so now we owe
everybody but like
we like everything was it was fine and
it was probably
it was all a facade right like now if
you really look into that
all that stuff you know it wasn't it
wasn't real but we were also as a
country we were happy and we were like
everything was going great and all that
[ __ ] and i think that that always
translates into music
um
so
it was a great it was a great uh time
the late 90s a lot of people look back
and it was all corny music it was like i
don't know the new radicals were pretty
neat to me like that [ __ ] was fun you
got a reason
yeah
you know i think that's the only record
they did yeah they have john my brother
did a whole deep dive on that yeah i
think they broke up like they broke up
right after that yeah i think it was
something they didn't care about the
duke fame or what was i think the dude
was a wild boy he was a wild boy he was
tough to talk about the other
group
is that dude that dude tried to do other
things through that group
gosh just who
oh i need you
i need you
i don't know gosh cherry cola they have
cherry cola in this song i was thinking
third or not third one savage garden oh
savage garden no they had a couple of
hits
they had like two hours savage garden
what about uh
we've got we've
he
got
tonight
were thinking about cherry uh
don't they tell me something about
cherry cola
cherry cola i don't know
song with cherry cola first of all not
eagle's the death metal
i was right really oh no savage garden
did fine for a little bit didn't they
yeah
they had maybe i think it was them that
they didn't care about the they didn't
like didn't they know they loved you
before they met you
isn't that who they are that is savage
garden i knew i loved
[Music]
yeah i tell my girl that sometimes she
she rolls her eyes at me yeah
she don't get it though not yet she yeah
yeah she gotta hear it a couple times
you know
i think there was something weird with
them where they didn't like the fame
oh i could see that yeah i mean
meanwhile that was that was a big thing
a lot of people in the 90s didn't like
the fame well i think the level of fame
that you would hit in the 90s is very
out of your control like the
obviously you love oasis we both love
oasis like their rise to fame is like
unprecedented and will never happen
again because the way that the 90s were
set up yeah like that rise to fame will
never exist again no and that's why it's
one of the coolest stories i think in my
mind yeah like their rise to fame and
then nirvana's rise to fame
um
it's just never gonna happen again take
a break from this episode to talk about
one of the best kratoms in the game
right now happy hippo i use uh kratom to
fire up my brain before any of my shows
podcasts uh even my punk rock shows it's
like a limitless pill uh best product
i've ever used best part it's all
natural okay so visit
happyhippos.com and use promo code thick
boy for 20 off for life again that's
happy hippo herbals.com and using promo
code thick boy for 20 off for life and
use that code as many time as you want
like i'm trying to think of the last
thing that hit that big like that i
think it would be the boy band uh era
my in my
opinion i think first of all one of the
coolest perspectives in
fame is definitely dave grohl's because
he is
he got he got to take this skyrocket to
the top
in like you know five months they went
from like nobody to everybody yeah
and then
he also experienced what occurred when
that fame
will bring you down yeah and so he got
to see that firsthand
um in the worst way the worst worst way
imaginable and even even right now and
then he got to see right and then now
he's got a whole different perspective
on it which is unfortunate but like then
he got to regroup and created another
thing that he controlled yeah and
verize that to fame for another 20
something yeah i think that's like the
coolest perspective on
fame that anybody could have and also
wildly unfortunate and he's also seen
like
the highs of it in the lows of it and
obviously taylor being gone is like the
worst thing because fame had to do with
his downfall too and his
i'm sure his addictions and [ __ ] but
yeah i i mean i don't think they they
still don't know what it is
exactly yet right doesn't sound great
but
i know he
he uh
you know
well no that's too into that no 2001
that was on tour
yeah
either way
that boy lived hard
we know that much
but it's an interesting perspective on
fame and he was able to rise in the 90s
and
um oh they think it was containing
psychotic drugs
so probably doing a little
lsd and
this is why you've been od on lsd he
might have been mixing when you when you
mix and match bro
especially with these things these days
you don't know if you're mixing a
matching
and then you got some [ __ ]
that that fentanyl is undefeated these
days you never know if it was like
something like that too because when
you're mixing a matching and then you're
on the road and you don't know who's
giving you what blah blah blah like
that's how yeah that's how petty got it
yeah that is how petty guys teddy just
needed some painkillers and he was
prince yeah and they just needed it and
then they didn't know what they were
getting it from and all that all of a
sudden just you get it from the wrong
person that stands for mary jane you
know yeah
hey you see what i did come on now
speaking of the 90s patty was crushing
the 90s
think about that to be killing it in
like a certain era and then continue
so like to your point dave grohl yeah
that's the person who was killing in the
90s and then continued and just
continued on i think people people hey
people
well a lot i mean people that know don't
snooze on it but when you really break
it down dave grohl's got a really cool
trajectory but all that stuff i mean i
think that we were able to in the 90s be
surrounded by
uh the ability to just continue to make
music continue to make pretty happy
music for the most part i mean the
grunge [ __ ] was the early 90s and then i
think once grunge died it was like what
about all this shiny what about sugar
ray and then yeah sugar right here
yeah third eye blind the goo dolls yeah
what about their blind is pretty sad
actually yeah actually i take that back
yeah but uh sugar ray what about uh
oh my god there's so many well those
corny dudes because when when kirk died
the same year that kurt died is the same
year that
um
definitely may be dropped
yeah and always just actively says i
wonder what how far apart that was
can we see
just tell me i know when kurt died
because yesterday was the anniversary of
his death oh what's the fifth yeah r.i.p
uh him and lane stanley from uh allison
chains so look up definitely maybe
release date yeah definitely maybe
so
one thing about casey on august 29th
august 4.
so
they were yeah no no not that much like
four months right
meanwhile they were working on the
record
yeah and they probably already had the
hits written yeah
yeah that
to be to be raised in that 90s era was
really cool because you could be very
diverse because we entered the 90s i
think i entered the 90s being just a
six seven eight year old kid with like
my dad's records in in my mind and like
i was just learning who the eagles were
you know james taylor my mom like carol
king [ __ ] like that okay
all that type of stuff and then
um
and then
all of a sudden the
nirvana and [ __ ] like that i remember
learning about rem and stuff like that
so then you're getting all that so i
wasn't really like understanding there
wasn't a point where i was like
understanding what hip-hop was then i i
don't know what it was
you got into hip-hop later well i just
loved boys to men and the funny thing
with r b was r b was like this
you didn't know but it was a gateway
drug to hip hop really like i didn't
know that but like boys to men like abc
bbd like it's also a gay gateway drug to
falling in love really quick i i say
that in seven i remember seventh eighth
grade i told this one girl i was like i
always know i got a crush on a girl when
i'll be listening to boys
i swear we're like the same yeah like
man i've been listening to two a lot
lately
and uh he had didn't have you hyped as
if like like yo it had me believing
listen to thank that right now listen it
had me believing yeah
i'm like man that i can get this script
oh did i watch i could get this i
watched uh the i'll make love to you
video and it's literally a dude writing
the lyrics of a song that he had just
heard and just giving to a girl so i was
like oh that's
yeah that's what it is so i remember i
took it was seventh grade i took annie
alemany to swayne park in cincinnati
ohio and i sang i do to her which was
off of the michael shawn wagner and
nathan's album
and
i first of all i didn't have any right
telling her i do in public and [ __ ] like
that
thank god there wasn't a preacher around
i'd have been married at 13.
that's such a ridiculous song he's like
just swearing that i'll love you yeah if
you sing boys too into a girl that's
legally binding that's yeah i actually
think i'm still married to her yeah
exactly i never thought about it that's
what it's saying that's what it did to
me i almost like i just had a lot of
false hope yeah because i believed in
those songs so much where i was like
yeah they said it right there i was a
thankless it was like a bible that was
like a bible to me yeah if a man think
it's so shall he get hopeless whatever
it is yeah i think that's corinthians
yeah
and uh
yeah i was like obsessed with
that music i loved uh singing i was
inquiring [ __ ] like that keith sweat i
would love i loved like bill bellamy's
top 10 list i would i would listen to
that a lot so that was like i was like
oh what is this like then you're like
what you're listening to music like this
and then r b was introduced in my life i
was like what is this what are black
people doing yeah
and
and boys to men
that two album was i was like obsessed
with that yeah the two
i'm still obsessed with that yeah like
what do you think the two i hope that i
i think that album probably still oh
i've revisited it recently strong no no
i'm talking about like the record sales
oh i can't even i can't even imagine
it's they're probably one of the most
popular from the 90s that still kill it
so anyways my mom
is the one
first of all look at the first six
tracks you tell me not every single one
of those could have been a single
and i thank you it's one of those
and i thought i had enough and then
oh
all around the world dude
you know vibin dude how is vibin not a
singer it probably was
well no it was because they had a didn't
they have a music video uh hopefully
they should have had a music video for
all this [ __ ] yeah water runs dries
track 12 dude and then on the end they
were like
bended knee 50 candles probably might
not have hit dude on bended knee is
right before water runs dry i think
about that think about that follow up
the last think about that follow up is
right next water on dry is right next to
i'll make love to you
if you're not [ __ ] by track eight
you've done you've done the whole thing
yeah yeah because the first the first
half is actually a little bit more uh
upbeat a little bit more swing
and then the last half is all like less
babyface wrote those yeah babyface was
like
let's switch up the second half of the
album yeah and then and then yesterday
was just like all right let's let them
know you can sing and harmonize yeah
it's a it's a it's a i'm
like i used to listen i used to listen
on bended knee on repeat
and i had like literally do you like
that more than i'll make love do you uh
i do like i'm bending knee a little bit
more too oh neat it's bro the best
bridge
yeah it's a crazy one
what what other new song bridge just
knocking that one out stop pointed
fingers the blame is on me the blame is
all right i want a new life and i want
it with you
if it feels the same then don't ever let
it go
begging you please come home come on i
know you i mean we're splitting ramps
yeah at least a turtle in the video yeah
she snuck in come on 90s was crazy crazy
and also like they were like okay but so
i feel like you and i are at a
generation that
i think we're at a specific generation
where because i don't know too many
people
pre-generation that
accepts newer music or was accepting of
newer music whereas you and i like i
feel like our generation even though we
came up in the era yeah even though we
came up in the era that we came up in
we're always searching for new i agree
because well i think even it's a weird
split that my brother's only two
like two years older than me but he is
very
into hi he's not searching not just not
to
like generalize uh that he's never
looking for new music he does do that
but he really loves his music his music
exactly that's amazing i think that
people done like their 40s and [ __ ] are
like all right pearl jam is as deep as i
go whatever like
nine inch nails i'm still bumping like
and it's like dude also that's great
that's great tool like sure it's
timeless stuff yeah
but like
there's new [ __ ] that really and also
sneak bobby brown and everyone says hey
come on now hey
come on who was running it like bobby
[ __ ] brown dude because instagram
cracks us up oh yeah i like him he'll
just randomly send me his king king
bobby brown i think bobby
[Laughter]
look he's just oh now he's getting sold
out go down to like want a video one um
scroll
look at my man
you couldn't tell them nothing right
there can't tell me
you can't
boston just a kid from boston that night
who he is oh he's got a biography
memorial day i'm checking that out yeah
that's an interesting life yeah very
interesting
did whitney put him on the coke or did
he do is it vice versa i don't know i
don't know i think whitney they got a
i think they were a wrecking ball that
was crazy
but they got something in common come on
on the album bobby but um
but i do think so
90s r b though
was like to me is the gateway drug to
hip-hop in general because
i wasn't an eight-year-old bumping
public enemy i wasn't a you're bumping
nwa and all that [ __ ] like i didn't even
know anything about that so then i get
obsessed with r b and [ __ ] and i really
loved two and then boys to men keys
going on and then the new jack swing
whole era that i didn't realize was
going on but i was like oh and what i
didn't realize was those beats actually
by the end of the 90s it's funny but r b
kind of faded by the end of the 90s and
what happened was those beats because of
diddy's influence just turned into
rap songs yup so diddy was the first one
to realize like oh let's just start
putting biggie on this 112 112 song or
let's put ella cool j on this boys to
mention yeah whatever like that so then
all of a sudden then you're getting that
and then did it had uh
hey love it yeah this is more than a
cross yeah there's one there was more
than the girls there was more and uh
shout out to what was the girl's name
cool j oh hey you had a crush on that
you took the swing apart oh annie yeah
shout out to you
more than a crush it felt it we hadn't
fallen out um
but um
so all that opened my ears and eyes to
like oh it's like oh i really like this
and then diddy
i was 10 11 years old and i just and my
parents just got divorced and i moved to
wellington uh place in cincinnati ohio
so then i'm taking the bus with all
those public housing in the area too so
then i'm on the bus and i'm like one of
you know 10 white people on a bus of 25
30 30 kids so then i'm in there
and black kids just black kids black and
brown
um there are some different ones too
because shout out to arturo shout out to
uh
you know all that [ __ ] but um
and so then i'm on the bus as a 11 12
year old i already really like boys to
man and all this [ __ ] new edition home
again album 1996. dude great album hit
me off is it isn't it
that's it
that is kind of like that's that's new
jack swing but then you yeah they had a
new they had rap on them with
uh
with um
what's his name ronnie and yeah yeah and
so
uh
then i'm on the bus
and then they're they're listening to
diddy and then they'll i'll never forget
being on the bus and then like they're
playing this song and it's like whoa
like whoa and i was like what is that
they're like you don't know black rob
and i'm like i don't know black rob
i don't know white rob
i got a buddy named bob yeah
and then i'm listening to that
and then and then you're like this and
then i'm like oh what is this yeah what
are the black people doing
people
[Laughter]
what are black people doing yeah
and that was like that was when it was
like a deep dive into it and then and
then you're in 96 97 98 which people
would argue is the golden era of yeah
all that [ __ ]
yeah i wonder i mean
cause like r b is still out there i
think it's just i
i think
the way it's put out there or what
they're singing about is
different well obviously
you don't want to i mean you have to
evolve you have to you can't just sing
the same [ __ ] that that last person was
just singing like you can't you can't be
look at listen to boys and men go i want
to be an rb singer and then try to do so
there's a type of show yeah because they
don't make them like that anymore i will
say there's a chicken there's a chick
named amber mark and i was there i was
just gonna bring her up she makes dope
like amber mark is [ __ ] amazing you
showed me yeah yeah another person you
showed me yeah you you're really good
because
anything you've ever showed me i've
actually like really [ __ ] with i uh
and i'm biased but i do think i have
like
a good ear for
i mean also you understand that and i
know what you would like yes i wouldn't
put you on to be like oh i think you're
like this yeah no you you send me
something yeah it's you're like you'll
like this and i i i do i appreciate you
saying that because yeah i take a lot of
pride in being like putting trying to
put people on [ __ ] yeah um but the the r
b [ __ ] now
i do think amber mark is probably
underappreciated but under we know amber
mark but um
new r b is interesting i mean you still
got miguel
uh yeah you've got like
jacquez is the king of r b right now i
don't even know who this [ __ ] is
all i know is he sings a song about like
i'd rather be with you and all your
[ __ ] look at amber martin she's
great also she produces all her own [ __ ]
she writes all her own [ __ ] and if
you're on this podcast and you really
appreciate chappelle's taste of music
with nirvana and [ __ ] she has a cover of
heart-shaped box that is so dope
she does she you showed me that
she did she did it she did a cover of
heart-shaped box which is like you're
like oh this is amazing like this is my
talent she's talented as [ __ ] and she's
got a song called uh she's only 28. i
think she's i think it's called put me
on
with drums
[Music]
yeah and it's very like and if i told
you and if i told you it was written in
1998 you'd be like oh okay yeah yeah
yeah yeah you'd be you'd be totally
understanding of it yeah
she's dope she's so badass she's cool
she just put out her
like
album yeah
that people have been going with music
where they kind of just been dropping
you know like a five song ep yeah or or
uh you know just like a single you know
here and there after a five song ep yeah
and then then they just dropped this
well because you get to see them grow a
little bit yeah and then i think by the
time they make an album because a lot of
people forget how hard an album is to
make hard
and finally you're like oh this is oh
this is your sound yeah this is 15 10 to
15 tracks of who you really are at this
point yeah and you're more mature but
but the the current the current r b i
actually think is
really nice i think that i think sir is
one of the better singer songwriters
her
her also yeah hdr she performed at the
grammys with travis uh they did they did
a lenny kravitz cover and she yeah she
plays guitar really [ __ ] well i saw
her live and she rips dude oh yeah she
plays did she start at the hollywood
board sorry the hollywood bowl um and uh
she
played guitar like four or five songs
yeah electric and acoustic really and
she ripped and then um good on her sir
is really dope to me he's on tde
um ari lennox has one of the doper
voices yeah i don't know if she's ever
figured out who's the guy that we really
like that's on that nipsy track
um
on the nipsy track
he's on the uh on it's off of nipsey's
album he sings the hook for it dope
voice he's from he's from la as well
is it that song with uh him and um
the one where they talk about
um go to pull up the nifty album the
victory lap album
just yeah type in victory lap
and i'll know exactly
um
i'm trying to think yeah
i was like
oh buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy's dope buddy has
one of the best buddy yep it's actually
a group
and the group i thought it was just one
guy but he he's the one guy is the
singer and songwriter type yeah buddy
has a buddy has one of my favorite um
npr tiny desks
he does a tiny desk bro they rip that
[ __ ] what what i appreciate appreciate
about tiny desk is anyone that goes on
tiny desk it's probably still dope yes
yes
probably i've never seen anybody bomb on
tiny that's what i'm saying i've never
seen a bad one even even bands that i've
never heard of in a style of music that
i probably would never listen to on a
regular i still go damn that was a good
performance
i like it because it's like this new age
of uh mtv unplugged yes that's exactly
what it is it's it's perfect they don't
put but but mtv and plug used to be like
all right we got to get nirvana we got
to get prints we got to get that yeah
actually the npr is exact the only it's
not the exact opposite in that way it's
the same thing but it's for these
up-and-comers and if you're big enough
and you want to still do it bieber can
still do it but it's also like let's put
these [ __ ] on that yeah
a band that i've really been uh really
loved lately uh turn style
which is like a hardcore baby my
nickname dog yeah turn okay hey
not really turn
yeah but um which is a hardcore band
which like no i've never seen a hardcore
band on npr unless i haven't seen it yet
but they stopped that day npr
acknowledged yeah you know a genre that
is very heavy and heavy in my heart you
know what i mean yeah that's the they do
have a lot of different genres it's one
of my bigger uh
places to identify new the r b [ __ ] and
i guess they call it like neo soul i
don't know what they call it but i know
i know the [ __ ] that is coming out now
because we
were talking about is like the r b [ __ ]
uh just to bring it back to that as i
actually think right now is some of the
best
r b
uh music going right now i think that
there's a lot there's a huge you just
really gotta dig deeper for [ __ ] that
you you know whoever you like now yeah
who i really like leon bridges yeah he's
great i don't even know if he's r b or
not yeah i don't i don't know what he
would be his i i i i discovered him on
npr like five you should you showed me
his npr mm-hmm and that's how i
cause i think you discovered them and
then you sent them to me yeah and i was
like man this dude's yeah amazing i've
seen him live and it is a good show yeah
and his his career trajectory has been
beautiful too and uh it's been nice it's
though it's cool to have that type of
[ __ ] now because it reminds me of some
of that [ __ ] that we loved growing up
and his his his sound is like
his early [ __ ] his early [ __ ] was like
is this in the diner in in the 60s yeah
yeah but now he's like really matured he
had
two albums ago good things he had a
little bit of like he and he's spoken
about it he had a lot of prince
influence on it too he's listening to a
lot of prints
um
it's really good
and then but then
then once once i got obsessed with all
the
the
hip-hop [ __ ] then i then i just dove so
deep on that [ __ ]
um and that was like
into high school and [ __ ] like that
and
and then to bring it all full circle
that's when i started diving deep into
these albums and i loved all these these
projects and [ __ ] like that
and by the time that to bring it back to
dilla by the time that dilla died what i
realized when i got obsessed with
dilla's i was like i'm gonna go look up
all the [ __ ] that he's done and then i
looked it up and and it was like oh he
did this album he did this album he did
i was like oh i've always loved him i
actually never even knew he did tribe
called quests uh the first this is how
crazy was to discover dilla at that age
when he had just passed was
to talk about what we were talking about
with the bill bellamy top 10 list and
[ __ ] like that and i was obsessed with
all that [ __ ] the first hip-hop sound
that i remember being
blown away by sonically and like not
knowing i was like what the [ __ ] is this
how do i get more of this yeah it was
tribe called quest find a way yep now
you caught my heart for the evening
then you confused things should i just
sit down oh come on
help me find my way now why you want to
go and do that
and so i was like
i was
i loved that i would go back to my dad's
apartment after school wait for that top
10 let's go down hopefully it was one
if it wasn't it was in the top five and
you you'd catch that video every day and
they would start off with them walking
on the beach yes come on and i was like
and i was like this [ __ ] is
so dope and it's great what's crazy to
me now is then i'm i'm having these
realizations about dylan i'm like oh
that was j dilla
he wasn't he was in so crazy q-tip was
the person to put him on discovered him
understood his
his timing and beats was something that
nobody had ever heard in hip-hop before
he completely changed how people produce
music he completely changed the timing
and rhythms of how people approached
npcs yeah and how like how the producers
even thought about the machine
he made the machine work for him versus
people used to make the sound of the the
sample would be the thing that you were
discovered by dj premier yeah yeah all
that [ __ ] it's like this it goes so deep
dude it's crazy so that was that was
we're a little out of time but
i got to do a round two with you
because there's there's a lot of things
we didn't get to yet oh man we didn't
get we didn't get to
the pop punk era oh i know
so that's we didn't we there's a lot of
things dude once those buildings fell
dude
hey come on come on now actually we'll
you know what [ __ ] we'll just do your
round two next week yeah let's do it
yeah we're just running back next week
run it back because uh there's so much
[ __ ] more yeah and i'll have it
mapped out to where like i love i
remember what we had talked about just
because music baby just because there's
so much [ __ ] more i do i i love first
of all i love your format about music
too because you know i love this [ __ ]
yeah yeah um so yeah i always do this
thing oh wait wait i'll i'll do
i remember some of the rapid questions
so i always like to do rapid questions
with people
um
favorite album
of all time
you know what it's it fluctuates so much
but i literally was just bumping it so
hard recently i was like i think
fantastic volume two might be like okay
one of my favorites that's a good all
the time
oh but you know what though i take that
back because i've said this before and
i'll say it again
uh
that's like my current [ __ ] but
timelessness and stuff like that uh
frank ocean's blonde
yeah yeah you know that that is it
that's for right that's around two come
on uh favorite um
favorite concert you've been to
um that's tough i think because of the
experience and like
it's like a top three but
i would have to say
when i went to see kanye life of pablo
yeah at the forum
on the floor the floating stage yeah he
played all the hits he didn't do a rant
it was kim's birthday kim's birthday so
he was in control he just did music it
was the best oh and then uh favorite
band or favorite artist
or both favorite artist of all time is
kanye west west okay
favorite band
favorite band um
the roots
you know there we go so all right at the
end of every episode i like to do a
playlist which i called the soundtrack
to the episode yeah something for people
to listen to because we talked about a
lot on here and i can't wait to i can't
wait to do round two because i mean yeah
there's so much there's so much more we
got to talk about we got to have amber
mark yes so we'll do
so
is that tracking one though we just go
back and forth so okay so we can do
amber mark put you on
is it put you on or put me on put you on
yeah you're right it has put you on yeah
all right you go for it
go for it we gotta do
um
i'm trying to think which boys to men to
do
i do would be too much because i did
sing that to anyone i don't know uh but
hey
i'm bending this
is the one um
i'll do
how many tracks do we get
we'll do 10 10 to 12.
uh we'll give them 12. because this is
yeah we talked about a lot all right
i'll i'll do
um
with you oh no it's like a dream come
true
yeah climax uh slum village it's called
no the slum is some village is the
artist the song is uh climax
and then i got it then off off that then
you hear that sonically and then you go
back to
uh find a way
try quest
and then i'll do
um
off that dilla
album i forget what they but uh which
one the one with fairmont we
um and then what else did we talk we
talked about um oh we got to do bobby
and whitney um
we got something in common is that what
it's called we got something we're just
typing in it might be something in
common yeah that's something we got
something
and then we gotta do common
ooh which one though
do you you do you know that album enough
we could do the light
yeah that's that's the one yeah yeah we
can nobody's gonna be mad at that yeah
no one's gonna be back that comes on
and then you'll be like oh damn he did
this [ __ ] yeah and then you go back and
look at bobby call
he's like he is white
um
what else did we talk about we talked
about um
[ __ ] because i was trying to think of
like this old school [ __ ]
i brought up les mis and [ __ ] that'd be
wild though you can't throw that on
there we can
throw whatever i know right these
[ __ ] um
but i was thinking about like this yeah
we didn't even get into the kanye area
jay-z round two no oh man
we got round two we got round two we got
round two we'll do round two next we
were on that we're on that r b tip yeah
um
um i'm trying to think because like you
know what's a good you know what's a
perfect example of the moment that i was
like oh this is what r b
and hip hop sounds like it is 112
featuring biggie and mace uh oh yeah
what we do yeah 112 uh big what's that
one called one only you only you only
you remix it's got to be the remix
that'll be the remix
um
that's like the perfect example to me of
like
especially that combination and that's
when that really started and that's when
i was like oh my god yeah what are black
people doing what are black
what are they up to that's the name of
this episode
i got another one yeah now you
uh oh now me yeah oh
damn
i might i might see i might throw a
little slower one a curveball yeah this
is where the people we can slow down
okay
so tony tony tone anniversary oh
he can't sp no he'd see he don't know
how to spell it
it's all spelled differently it's tony
tony to and i
t-o-n-e
t-o-n-y
i think it's actually tony first
well yeah it don't matter yeah somebody
figured out raphael sadiq
anniversary anniversary i might see my
favorite was the one
uh there's a tony tone and tony
featuring dj quick yeah it was that was
that
that's the new jack swing [ __ ] i forget
what that is come on let's get let's get
down let's get down we can throw it on
dj quick is too much for these people
yeah they don't they don't deserve it
actually y'all do do your own deep dive
on dj quick um i was going to do and so
uh we mentioned sir that's those i was
um what's my what's my one with sir dude
i love johnny redcorn yes it's such a
good song i like the song is he called
john redcorn or johnny i think john read
john redcorn yeah
um
i think it's john redcorn yeah john
redcorn yep how many were we at casey
who is a character from king in the hill
yeah
he was who he was always who was always
getting cheated on yeah he was [ __ ]
home girls uh yeah
it's they uh not dale song about just
getting worse yeah yeah
that's ten let's do two more to top them
off all right
um
um
is it me
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do mary j blige
oh damn
since we're getting into it
because that b goes hard and i think
it's called b it's either called happy
or b happy
all i really want is to be happy
and i'll do and honestly like there's i
know there's a lot of dill on there but
the beautiful thing about dilla is like
you can
it just keeps going but i would do dilla
and my it's my one of my favorite solo
tracks by him is won't do
and it's just about him loving [ __ ]
multiple women
[Laughter]
one won't do two is not enough for me
damn
come on now and there it is
all right uh
he he also makes a really good fifth
element uh reference in that track shout
out to you guys
shout out to chris tucker mm-hmm
uh
i have some tour dates coming up oh
where you going yeah i'll be in salt
lake city come on now uh where the
white's at yeah where the whites at
they're in salt lake where the white
women i'll be there oh i'll be there so
this comes out thursday april 8th and
april 9th friday and saturday salt lake
city at wise guys comedy club then may 6
may 7th oh we're pulling uh white mike's
going to be with me in san diego yep at
a new comedy club in san diego called
mic drop comedy club i'm doing the
opening weekend of this club okay so we
should and a double plug if you if
anybody is coming to that weekend i'm
doing a different show on april 5th the
night before this week sucks tonight
which will be like it won't be the same
[ __ ] at all so if you want to double up
it'll be super fun fun show on thursday
and then um
on may 5th i should say and then may
12th i'll be doing a one-nighter in the
hometown and phoenix had stand up live
and then later on uh down the road in
the hot summer
uh meatball is coming with me pharrell
to providence he's coming to kick him
they're gonna oh i was like he ain't
doing it yeah
i might have to pull up on these
problems
rhode island they got a east side of
providence i thought it was just
providence
it's like look man he ain't that big
anyways and then uh follow michael
turner on socials at turner comedy
is that on everything at turner comedy
and i just dropped some uh a video on
don't tell comedies youtube this week
too that you guys can check out
he's a good stand-up comedian yeah uh
he's up and coming he's doing the damn
thing out here uh especially because he
moved out here the day kobe died come on
come on who's who's been tough yeah
who's been doing well after that
not me all right so we'll see you next
week for a round two on this uh
with the with mr white mike let's run it
back we'll run it back
appreciate you bro all right
you